la policía está buscando a dos
sospechosos por este ataque en el lado
una ciudad predominantemente
ultraortodoxa en el centro de israel
según testigos dos hombres uno armado
con un arma de fuego y otro con un
cuchillo largo o un hacha comenzaron a
atacar a peatones causando la muerte de
al menos tres personas y al menos cuatro
heridos uno de ellos de gravedad
mientras los residentes de la han
recibido la orden de no salir de sus
casas la policía continúa su búsqueda
con la sospecha de que los dos atacantes
pueden haberse trasladado a cisjordania
los grupos islamistas de hamás yihad
islámica calificaron el hecho de un acto
heroico pero evitaron adjudicarse el
atentado y lo enmarcaron como una
respuesta al ingreso de fines judíos a
la explanada de las mezquitas hay que
destacar que es el sexto ataque en
israel desde finales de marzo sumando en
total 18 muertos
bueno federico y como se enmarcan en los
hechos cuando tanto judíos como
palestinos están en medio de
conmemoraciones importantes
si precisamente este jueves se están
culminando las celebraciones de por el
aniversario 74 de la creación del estado
de israel que para los palestinos como
lo describía said es considerado la
nakba o catástrofe que recuerdan cada 15
de mayo en este contexto hay que
destacar que esta mañana la policía
israelí volvió a permitir el ingreso de
fieles judíos en la explanada de las
mezquitas un lugar que es reservado para
el culto musulmán y este tipo de
movimientos es visto por los fieles
musulmanes y por los palestinos como una
provocación es por esto que se había
había advertido jamás en los días
previos que cualquier ingreso de fieles
no musulmanes a este espacio iba a ser
considerado una provocación estos
ingresos son custodiados por la policía
y se habían suspendido durante las
últimas semanas de celebración del
ramadán pero justo en este día de la
independencia para israel fue que
comenzaron nuevamente los ingresos y se
da este ataque